Support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft.com/people ready.
I'm Alice Rivlin and I'm a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution.
I think we're in a positive the
innovation cycle,
which is definitely not over.
Uh,
there are lots of things happening in
new electronic,
uh,
applications in new,
healthcare applications.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that's going to power our economy going
forward and is not a moment at which I
think anyone can say.
We've run out of ideas at the moment.
We've run out of credit now.
We are,
uh,
a financing,
people's new ideas.
But,
uh,
we need to turn that around.
There are certainly risks of not
investing in technology.
There are bigger risks of investing in
the wrong technology.
Uh,
the landscape is littered with
corporations and government agencies,
uh,
that a revamped their computer systems,
quickly and,
uh,
caused more chaos than the advantage of
investing in new technology.
So the bottom line is got to do it very
carefully and have some very skilled
people doing it.
Computers and telecommunications have
revolutionized our,
uh,
the way we conduct business and the way
we conduct our lives.
Um,
the,
uh,
problems are that we're overwhelmed with
too much information and too much noise
going on.
I think the,
uh,
the real problem of surviving these a
wonderful innovations is,
uh,
to,
keep a bit centered to this matters for
business.
It matters for ordinary people,
uh,
and,
not get overwhelmed and distracted by
the rapidity and the volume of the
information flow.
Technology is helping the government a
lot and could help more
basically,
a lot of things go more smoothly.
The government is involved in huge
information collection,
uh,
operations.
Uh,
it essentially runs a huge insurance
companies,
uh,
called social security.
A lot of information needs to be
collected and processed,
uh,
quickly.
Uh,
that's a certainly a change the way the
government operates.
One of the agencies that has had most a
benefit,
but also most trouble in getting into
the modern computer age,
uh,
is the internal revenue service.
Uh,
taxes are certainly processed more
quickly and efficiently than they used
to be.
But there's a long way to go,
uh,
in improving,
those,
uh,
computer systems that,
technology has also,
uh,
given,
average people more access to government
information and,
um,
uh,
and help.
Uh,
you can go on lots of websites and find
out what's available to help your
particular business or help you,
uh,
as a,
a taxpayer on a particular,
uh,
problem.
Um,
there's a long way to go.
Uh,
but both the federal government and
state and local governments are a much
more effective than they used to be
because they have taken advantage of
modern technology.
Most major government agencies have a
chief technology officer and ought to
have a most states and cities,
uh,
do as well.
Um,
they,
uh,
clearly technology is extremely
important to the functioning of any
large organization,
whether it's a corporation or a
government agency,
and somebody very highly qualified has
to be
sure.
Support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft.com/people ready.